was the moon landing faked the other day
I went with two friends to see first man
the new film about Neil Armstrong and
the moon landing starring Ryan Gosling
and on the way it became pretty clear
that one of these friends of mine wasn't
totally convinced that the moon landings
really happened now I'm sure all of us
know one or more people like this and
people tend to cite all kinds of
different alleged evidence that proves
the landings must have been faked in
this case my friend was caught up on the
idea that the recordings of the
conversations between the astronauts and
Mission Control showed that even though
there should have been a delay of a
certain amount of seconds accounting for
the distance between the Earth and the
moon one of the astronauts responses was
too quick proving that they were in
reality back on earth where there is no
delay
I'm not going to debunk every single
conspiracy theory related to this
including supposed unexplainable shadows
the apparent movement of the American
flag and others and the reason why is
that those debunking zhh are readily
available online NASA itself has issued
rebuttals Mythbusters did a whole
episode on the subject and there are
substantial third party evidence for the
landings you can even just read the
Wikipedia article on it and check the
sources in the links I just want to shed
light on one specific point in order for
there to have been a conspiracy in the
moon landings literally about four
hundred and eleven thousand people would
have had to have been in on it this was
the number of people working on the
program mostly engineers scientists and
technicians and that is the number of
people that would have had to remain
silent since July 1969 in order to keep
the truth a secret and so I would say
that the idea that the moon landings
were faked is so unlikely as to be
considered completely implausible in the
end it was infinitely easier to actually
land on the moon than to try to fake it
and cover it up